acquisition.com is the wealth machine
that is behind Alex and Layla's media
like how cool would it be if Jeff Bezos
and Warren Buffett and Elon Musk and all
those guys had documented everything
that they learned throughout that path
all we get is these Snippets they're so
little and they're gonna die and we're
gonna lose it we're gonna lose all those
lessons but seeing the scores of
businesses that are using the stuff in
the books and the courses and YouTube
and podcasts Tick Tock and Instagram and
use those and the message I get every
day of like dude you helped me go from a
million to five million a year you help
me go from you know quit my job and then
start my dog walking business those
stories I know that I will probably
never meet most of them the fact that
it's happening just amps me